I was
very clear that
the person running against Hillary
Clinton was not up to the job,
that it was going to be chaotic,
that the job of president is not a joke
and that it would cause problems.
And to see citizens
storming through the Capitol
It was surreal and it was frightening
and deeply, deeply disappointing.
Former first lady Michelle
Obama is sharing her
thoughts on January six
last night with Stephen Colbert.
Her new book, The Light
We Carry, is out today.
In it,
she speaks very bluntly
about how she felt when former
President Trump won the 2016
presidential election.
It shook me profoundly
to hear
the man
who replaced my husband
as president
openly and unapologetically
using ethnic slurs, making selfishness
and hate somehow acceptable,
refusing to condemn white supremacists
or to support people
demonstrating for racial justice.
It shocked me to hear him
speaking about
differentness as if it were a threat.
It felt like something more,
something much
uglier than a simple political defeat
for perspective on that comment and more.
Let's bring in
NPR's All Things Considered,
Juana Summers.
She sat down with Michelle Obama.
And thank you
so much for joining us this morning
on what is a fascinating conversation,
just to hear her speak out so candidly.
And one thing I noticed
from your conversation with her is
the tone of this
book is a lot different
than the tone of the other book
that people might be familiar with.
That's absolutely right.
It is still partially a memoir.
She peels back the layers,
much like she does in her acclaimed
book, Becoming
which came out back in 2018.
But she told me that she intentionally
wanted this book
to be more practical,
to offer people a guidebook,
a road map of sorts, to chart a path out
during difficult times.
She told me that she wrote this book
largely in isolation during the pandemic,
with only a close group of people
by her side who were giving input.
And it gave her
a lot of time to look inward
and think about
what type of tools
she could offer
to the type of people
across the country
and around the world
who constantly are writing her in
asking her for advice on how to solve
some of the biggest problems
that they're experiencing in their lives.
When I think of Michelle Obama,
I think of bravery,
and that's just like what comes to mind.
But what I love is in this book,
she opens up about
when she was really scared and fearful
and when she almost let that fear stand
in the way of history.
Let's listen to that
and get your thoughts on the other side.
Here it is.
I think the
most anxious I've ever been in my life
was when Barack told me
for the first time
that he wanted
to run
for president of the United States.
I found the prospect of it
actually terrifying and perhaps worse
as we carried on a conversation off
and on
over the course of a few weeks
late in 2006.
He made it clear
that the decision was really up to me.
It's strange
to think
that I could have altered
the course of history with my fear,
but I didn't I said yes.
100% true.
I love it. 100% true.
What do you think?
I think it's something, etc.
Even though you're talking about
someone who's a former first lady, it's
just this really relatable sentiment
for anyone
who's been in a long term relationship.
Anyone who's in a marriage,
where in marriage
you have to have those give
and take those conversations.
To hear her
openly acknowledge
that she was fearful
of what this would mean for her family,
her children, her career,
how this would catapult
their life is a really unique revelation.
Then, of course,
seeing the ways
in which their family was examined
and cross-examined and scrutinized
during their eight years
in the White House.
In a sense,
I thought it was a really telling moment
to hear her
open up
and own that moment of intimidation.
Yeah.
So you want to here's
the interesting thing.
You know, when I was telling Poppy,
that's 100%
truth is
I was
the local anchor in Chicago
when Barack Obama was a state senator,
and then he became senator
and then he ran for president.
And I remember that this book,
long story short,
is the Michelle Obama that I know.
Not that I'm like best friends with them,
but I do know
that likes to introduce them
like chicken dinners
as a local anchor, like,
you know, Barack and Michelle Obama.
And so this was the
Michelle Obama
that Chicagoans knew,
that the constituents knew.
She didn't want to run for president.
No, not And even
she had a hard time actually running
and being for becoming being first lady.
And so this is a book becoming
this great is a great book.
There's no shade to Michelle Obama.
This is all praise for her.
But this is the real book.
This is what she really thinks.
This is personal
and
I think
that this is actually more relatable
to women, you know, who have careers
and then have to sort of sometimes
take a backseat to their husbands
because their house,
they put their husbands careers first.
And exactly how she felt
about Donald Trump
and what he did to the country.
This is it.
You saw her face on inauguration day.
And this book is a reflection of that.
I think that's absolutely right.
And you heard her to describe her family
in this book as this hopeful and earnest
black family that believed in hard work
that catapulted into the White House.
And then after eight years
of what she describes
as progress and achieving
and believing in those principles
for the country to in her
words, has repudiated
what her family stand for.
She expresses a great deal
of vulnerability
about what that was like for her,
that self-questioning of.
Did we do enough? Were we enough?
What does this say about us?
That this is the term the country makes?
And she talks about that
so incredibly openly.
I have to say,
she seems like someone
who really wants to be a helper.
She's providing
tangible things that have worked for her.
She talks about picking up
those knitting needles.
And what that has meant for her
and how that was
something that offered her
calm and steadiness
in a moment of global instability.
So I think it was a really interesting
turn for her,
and I'm excited
to see what she has to say about it
as she heads out on her book tour
that starts today.
Did you think that watching
I don't know if you guys noticed.
I watch them very closely
on inauguration day
when Donald Trump became president,
Donald Trump was inaugurated. And
I could tell like the dynamic
between her and her husband
he was like, we can get through this,
we can get through this.
And she was like just like kind of
she didn't want to really be there.
She was doing her duty,
but she was not having a look
at their face.
Yeah, it's really fascinating.
In the book,
she describes her husband
as the greatest disrupting
force of her life
and talks about that
counterbalance between the two of them.
And I do remember watching their faces
very closely on Inauguration
Day from our studios
just down the street from me
all here in D.C.
and seeing the contrast
and how they were approaching that,
even though no words were said
between the two of them.
It was an incredibly powerful moment.
I don't think I'll forget Juana Summers.
I also love
what she said about the pandemic,
and I think that was really relatable
for people with the feeling
that she felt being it,
being at home, writing this book
Juana Summers, this is a great interview.
Thank you so much for sharing
more of it with us this morning.
Thank you very much for having me.